Good morning everyone.
Augustus founded the Julio,
Claudia and dynasty.
Uh,
the name says it all.
Julio,
Claudia and Julio for the Julian side of the family.
Julius Caesar Augustus,
uh,
the Claudia,
the Claudia and for the Claudia and side of the family that was Augustus.
His wife's from a full Augustus,
his wife,
uh,
from a,
for her,
her side of the family,
excuse me,
the Claudia and side of the family and there were four emperors in the Julio,
Claudia and dynasty.
These were tybee,
serious Caligula,
Claudius and neuro,
every one of them.
All four made an important contribution to the evolution of Roman architecture
and we'll talk about the contributions of those for today.
But we'll also see that the single most important contribution from the
standpoint of Roman architecture was by Nero,
the notorious Emperor Nero,
which is why I do call this lecture,
no tour,
notorious Nero and his amazing architectural legacy,
an architectural legacy that would have been impossible without some of the
earlier concrete constructions that we've already discussed.
Specifically the frigging Daria up Pompei and also the thermal bath at Baia,
which I remind you of here.
The so called Temple of Mercury.
We see it again with its dome made out of concrete construction,
a view from the exterior and down here at the left of view of the interior of
the monument.
And I remind you of the way in which that is designed so that light streams
through the oculus in the dome down on to the sides of the wall,
uh,
creating light effects,
a circle,
uh,
that,
that cohort corresponds to the shape of the opening above,
uh,
and then falling initially on the pool of water that would have been located
there as well as across the,
uh,
walls,
which probably would have been,
that was certainly stuccoed over and probably would have been covered with
mosaic.
So a very spectacular interior indeed.
And one again,
that had an important impact as we'll see on the architectural designs of the
Roman Emperor Nero.
I want to begin though with the first of the Julio,
Claudia and emperors and that is with Tiberius and you see a portrait of
Tiberius now on the screen.
Just to give you a sense of what he looked like.
A Tiberius again,
the son of Livia by a former marriage,
the elder son of Libya by a former marriage,
uh,
who becomes a emperor of Rome right after Augustus.
And the portrait that you see here is a marble portrait of Tiberius that is now
in the knee,
Carlsberg,
glip ditech in Copenhagen.
Tiberius was emperor of Rome from 14 to 37 a d.
And with regard to architecture,
he completed projects begun by Augustus.
He also was responsible for restoring Republican buildings that had fallen into
sin,
into severe disrepair by his reign.
And this included several temple's a basilica warehouses and also a theater.
Tiberias also initiated some new building projects in Rome.
These included a temple to the divine Augustus temple to a d was our goose does
his divine adoptive father because Augustus was made a god is Caesar had been
before him at his death.
Tiberius also put up a series of arches to his relatives and also a camp for the
Praetorian guard.
But what we'll see about Tiberius is that his real passion was not the public
architecture that Augustus had been so fond of.
Think the forum of Augustus and the Temple of Marzel tour or the Arra pocket
goose die,
which were among a Augustus is most important building projects.
Tiberius was interested in stead in private architecture.
Architecture is sense for himself and his nearest and dearest.
And he began a palace on the Palatine Hill.
He did not think the small modest house of Augustus despite the fact that it had
those nicely painted walls.
He did not think that that be fit his own grand juror.
Uh,
and he began a major palace on the Palatine Hill on the northwest side of the
Palatine hill and he renovated and built villas elsewhere outside of Rome,
especially on the spectacular island of Capri.
And indeed during the reign of Augustus and also the reign of Tiberius,
that family that the Augustan and Julio,
Claudia and family built 12 villas.
Count them 12 villas on the island of Capri.
One more spectacular than the next.
It's worth mentioning by the way that Augustus is tastes even in villas with
somewhat more modest than Tiberius.
Augustus used to decorate his villa.
We are told a with dinosaur bones and things like that of historical interest.
Whereas Tiberius spared no expense in introducing every luxury of possible in to
his villas with regard to the palace on the Palatine Hill,
the so called Domus Tybee Arianna,
I just want to mention it in passing,
there's very little that survives of the substructures,
that type Bearius was responsible for beginning a for that palace.
They were made out of concrete construction and you can see here what's called
the Cleveland Palatino,
which is a ramp way leading from the Roman forum up to the hill and you can see
some of the remains of those substructures over here.
The ones that we see we're probably restored later in pro,
may not,
may or may not date to the Thai Berrien period,
but they give you some idea of the sort of construction that he began on the
Palatine Hill.
And I mentioned this just because we'll see that Caligula and some of the other
emperors continue to add to this palace.
And then the entire,
uh,
Palatine hill is redesigned by the emperor demission in the late first century.
A D much more interesting and much more.
And there's much more information for us to,
uh,
to look at are the villas on the island of Capri.
And I'm going to show you one of the best preserved from that island.
Uh,
the so called Villa Joe vis the village Ovis the villa of Jupiter,
which is an interesting name when you think about it for a villa,
for the emperor Tiberius,
the village Ovis,
which was put up,
uh,
some time in the years in which Tiberius was emperor,
that is from 14 to 37.
It's a spectacular place,
beautifully situated.
And I'm going to take you there today.
Now,
the only way to get to the island of coppery,
which by the way is one of my very favorite places in the world.
I don't know how many of you been there,
but it's quite extraordinary.
Uh,
the island of copper,
you can't jet to the island of copper.
You have to arrive there by boat.
Uh,
and most people take a boat,
uh,
if,
unless they have a private yacht.
But those of us who don't have to take a boat either from Naples,
uh,
usually a hydrofoil,
although they have larger boats as well,
a hydrofoil from Naples or from Posey Tano.
And I actually show you this is a view on the left hand side of the screen,
a posy Tano on the Amalfi coast.
You go down to the beach,
there's a place where you can pick up a hydrofoil takes a very short time,
half an hour or so,
less little bit less to get over to the island of coppery from Posey Tonah.
So we're sitting on one of those hydrofoils,
or at least eight of us are,
cause that's usually what they fit.
Uh,
and we are making our way from Posey Tano toward coppery as you go there,
if the weather is good enough and if the,
if the sea is calm enough,
uh,
they will take you to see the famous grottoes,
the Green Grotto,
and also the blue grotto.
Uh,
and,
uh,
again,
I can just give you a little sense here in this view of how blue is blue.
I mean,
it's really a neon blue.
When you go to see the blue grotto,
it's a spectacular sight and a very special color blue that you really don't see
anywhere else in the world.
So they'll drive you around in the hydrofoil to see the grottoes and then you
eventually get to the dock at coppery.
And this is what you see as you get off the boat at the island of Capri.
Uh,
a very,
uh,
again,
very beautiful spot to visit.
As you go up,
you make your way from the doc,
uh,
up to the finished color,
take the finical or up to the main part of town.
Uh,
and one of the first things you see is the popular bar t Berio.
I show it to you,
not to,
it's a fun place to go,
but I show it to mainly because it's one of these examples of the way in which
the Roman emperors have had a lasting impact even today that so many of these
bars and restaurants and so on are named for a Rome's emperors or for some of
the monuments that we'd been studying in the course of this semester.
And this bar is no exception.
And in fact,
if you go,
if you go through the doors that lead into the interior of the bar,
you will see a,
a,
a portrait of Tiberius etched on the doorway.
So Tiberias very much throw lives and thrives in the center of downtown coppery.
Uh,
still today what most tourists go to coppery to see besides just to walk around
the magnificent island and to test out some of the beaches,
which tend to be on the rocky side,
uh,
is to see the most famous rocks of coppery.
And these are the so called Farchioni.
You see them here,
you go up to the so called gardens of Augustus and then up to a spot where you
can see these particularly well.
They're magnificent.
They are,
uh,
a the landmark spot on the island of Capri and they have survived,
coastal landslides and see erosion to look as as wonderful as they still do
today.
And this is of course the photo op on the island.
I don't think there's anyone who visits coppery who doesn't take a photo or have
a photo taken of themselves at the far ione.
The villa that I wanted to show you is again,
the best preserved villa of Tiberius on coppery.
Uh,
and again,
I mentioned that it's called the village Novus and a dates to 14 to 37.
And it's,
it's a trek to get up there.
Uh,
you,
you have to walk.
Essentially the streets are such that there are no cabs or cars that can get you
there.
You have to,
to make it on your own.
And there are two paths I've made the mistake of taking the floor arduous path,
which looks like this,
uh,
to get up to the top.
But there are,
there's another path also that takes you by,
uh,
some very attractive houses and villas which are fun to see.
And you will see the most,
the largest lemons has anyone ever been on the island of Capri.
And you'll see the largest lemons in,
in,
on coppery as well as on the Amalfi coast in general that you've ever seen
anywhere.
Gigantic Lemons on lemon trees as you make your way up to,
uh,
the villa,
the villa jove is now here is a plan of the village office as well as a cross
section from the Ward Perkins Textbook.
And if we look first at the cross section,
at the upper most part of the screen,
you will see the way this,
this building was made.
Or you will see that the architects have taken advantage of developments in
concrete construction to create a series of barrel vaults in tears.
And those barrel vaults and tears are,
are where are the cisterns of the villa,
where,
where the water was kept to supply the baths and the kitchen.
And so on of the villa.
You see those there.
And in this plan down here,
you can see the cisterns again and the way in which a pavement has been placed
on top of those tiers of barrel bolts to create a very large court here.
The entrance way into Tiberias is villa on coppery,
uh,
was over here.
You can see a series of columns for in total,
uh,
that you see as you make your way into the entrance way of the villa.
Along this side of the villa,
which is the southern side of the villa,
you see the baths not surprisingly placed on the southern side,
extensive bath structure,
uh,
for the emperor.
On the western side,
you see a series of rooms that are for the entourage of Tiberius.
The kitchen is located on this side as well.
And then perhaps the most important room of the house from our standpoint,
the hall or the Owl Aula,
the Allah of Tiberius,
his villa at coppery.
And you can see the shape of that Allah.
It's a kind of Hemi cycle,
uh,
with large picture windows that allow views that lie outside and it should
remind you of the second phase of the Ville of the mysteries in palm pay,
where we also saw that attractive bay window with the panoramic views out beyond
the panoramic views were much more spectacular here than even in,
uh,
from the villa of the mysteries.
Because as I think you can see also from this site plan,
uh,
that this is located right at the edge of a promontory.
Uh,
it's in fact 1095 feet above sea level and you get some incredible views of,
uh,
of the sea and of other islands from this location on this side.
The northern side of the structure is where the apartments of Tiberius,
we're located a series of rooms for the emperor himself and including also an
imperial lodge where he could walk out and get some attractive panoramas
privately on his own.
You can also see that there is a corridor that leads from the private apartment
to this very long walkway that is located right at the edge of the cliff on this
side.
This is called technically an ambu lot,
tio,
a m,
B,
u,
l a,
t,
I,
O n,
Omd Nulato.
And it was just for that.
It was for,
for,
for taking pleasant walks,
getting nice views of the sea from there,
especially for the emperor and special invited guests.
And right in the center was a try Klinean you see it right here at Tri Klinean
or dining room where the emperor could dine a and could look out again over,
uh,
views that were,
possible from this particular locale.
This is a view,
unfortunately in black and white,
but it's the only one that I had that gives you a sense of the remains today
from above the extent of those remains.
And you can see again,
the concrete construction,
I think quite well from this as well as the fact that although all the
foundation walls are there,
there's no decoration,
the ceilings are all are missing.
Uh,
and so on and so forth.
You see the sister in here,
the location of the owl up here,
the uh,
the,
uh,
area for the entourage of Tiberius and the private apartment on that side,
a church and a statue on a base were added later.
And so of course you need to think those away.
This is a view of some of the remains as they look today.
Just to give you a sense that when you're actually up there and wandering
around,
uh,
the walls don't go up all that far,
but you can also see that they,
they do preserve the entire plan of the structure,
which is why we have such a good idea of what it looked like in antiquity and
how all of those pieces fit together.
You can see that the construction is concrete and the facing his stone,
a irregular stone work,
the kind of openness and care him work,
uh,
that we've seen elsewhere in Campania.
Because remember this is a,
this is an island,
but it's off the coast of Naples Pompei and a plant as it is in that same
general area of Italy.
And this,
this is one view and one I have many more spectacular ones in this one,
but this is one that she gives you a sense of the sort of thing.
You can see this one I took right from I think from near the um,
uh,
from near the [inaudible].
Uh,
just to give you an idea of what you see from their beautiful views of the sea
in some,
some,
some areas you can see the rocky outcroppings as you look down.
And then views of some other islands in the area.
For example,
Ischia and so on.
The successor to Tiberius was a man by the name of Caligula Caligula became
emperor at the death of Tiberius.
And we see a portrait of him here on the right hand side of the screen.
Just again,
to give you a sense of the man,
he had a very short,
he was very young when he became emperor of Rome.
He had a very short rain,
only three years,
uh,
and he was a somewhat unbalanced and it was not long after he became emperor.
Oh by the way,
he was very popular when he was a boy.
He was a prince,
a very popular,
he used to run around the military camps with his family,
uh,
in a little military costume.
And he wore these distinctive military boots called the colleague a cal Iga,
which is how he got the nickname Caligula from those boots.
He was extremely popular with everyone and everyone was quite excited when he
became emperor of Rome.
But his power went to his head.
He became a desk spot.
And,
uh,
he spent most of his time cavorting with his three sisters.
I show you them here on a,
uh,
on a coin.
Uh,
then they're all named Agra Pina.
Julia Andrew Scilla was his favorite.
So of course she's in the center there to Scilla.
Uh,
and uh,
he also did strange things like conduct wars,
fat,
you know,
fat full wars,
essentially four wars with FAU enemies.
I,
for example,
his war against Britain,
so,
so to speak.
Uh,
and he also spent a good deal of time trying to work it out so that his horse in
key Todd has,
could become a senator.
So this gives you some idea of the kind of man we're dealing with here.
He was occupied with all of that and really not that much with architecture.
And again,
he was only on for for a very short time.
So there was a limit to what kinds of architectural contributions he could make,
but he didn't make none.
I mean he made some and in fact one of them is particularly important.
Uh,
and I want to emphasize those two here.
So again,
Caligula was emperor between 37 and 41,
and he had little public building again.
He,
he,
he uh,
continued the tradition of tybee serious and that is in having much more
interest in private villa architecture then in public architecture.
Uh,
but again,
it's only fair we know as we judge him in terms of his architectural,
a contribution.
I think it's only fair to remind ourselves that again,
he was only emperor for three years.
If he had been ember longer,
perhaps his contribution would have been a greater,
he did finish several buildings begun by Tiberias.
And we're going to see this as a pattern that is emperors coming to the fore and
completing buildings,
uh,
by their predecessors.
And he did build a couple of new things,
including two new aqua ducks and a circus located near what is now Vatican City.
He added,
he thought the Domus tybee Ariana was a terrific idea.
And consequently he added to that palace.
That's the palace that Tiberius began on the slopes of the Palatine hill.
But his main interest was villas outside Rome.
He built a number of those when I'm not talking about coppery now,
those were already built and he could go down and enjoy those as emperor of
Rome.
But he wanted to ring Rome with a series of villas and he began that work.
And later on,
according to Pliny,
the elder Rome was a ring with the villa's,
not only of Caligula but also of Nero.
So these were going up a pace around the city of Rome itself.
The single most important contribution though that,
uh,
Caligula made,
and it is very significant,
is to alter.
It was during his reign,
during his brief reign that the recipe for Roman concrete construction was
altered.
What they did was make the decision to lighten it up and they did that by taking
the stone rubble that had been used in the mixture of concrete for some time.
Uh,
taking that stone rubble and dispensing with it,
getting rid of it because it was too heavy and mix the liquid mortar instead
with a very porous yellow Tufa.
And also with pumice,
which is a soft light stone resembling cork.
So when you think of replacing heavy rubble was something that resembles cork,
uh,
you get the sense that that is going to lead to lighter doms lighter domes are
going to lead to domes that are able to span greater spaces.
So this is no small accomplishment.
This is very,
very significant.
It happens during the reign of Caligula and we'll see already today that the,
uh,
so called Golden House or dome salary of Nero would not have been possible.
The span of that dome would not have been possible without this change in the
recipe in concrete that happened under [inaudible].
The other development under Caligula that I want to make reference to really has
more to do with religious practice,
but it has also has an important impact on architecture.
And that is the impact of mystery cults on Roman religion.
I think I've mentioned to you already that the Romans practiced,
uh,
a state religion and that state religion was considered the religion that
everyone should adhere to.
But over time,
because of Rome's connections to other parts of the empire,
especially the eastern empire,
a whole host of different kinds of religions,
mystery,
religions,
exotic religions,
began to infiltrate Rome.
They came back through the army,
they came back through commerce to Rome.
And initially they were not accepted.
You couldn't,
uh,
you were not allowed to practice these openly.
And so we saw an example was the Ville of the mysteries where,
uh,
the woman of the house created a special room room number five for the
celebration of the cult of Dionysus because that was considered a secret
religion at that particular point.
But these mystery religions Caligula himself showed some interest in them and
they began,
it began to look as if perhaps they would be able to begin to come up from
underground.
They didn't during his reign,
but I think,
uh,
again,
his contribution in that in that way was also an important one.
They did continue to have to meet in secret and one sector in particular I want
to make reference to today,
the so called neopathy Korean sect.
Uh,
because we will see in the next monument that I want to show you that it was
that sect that was celebrated in a very interesting underground basilica that I
want to turn to now.
It doesn't date to the time of collegial,
in fact,
it's a little bit later in the reign of Claudius,
but I want to show it to you here because again,
it was collegial as you know,
beginning to be more accepting of these kinds of things that led in part to
their proliferation initially underground and above ground as well.
This is the so called underground basilica because it is located underground
dates to around Aidy 50.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you can see from this site plan,
it's location.
I can see it,
mark basilica up there.
Uh,
and you can see that it's near a street.
We've already talked about the via Prajna,
Stena in Rome,
which you'll remember is one along with the via lobby conda that came and
converge on the tomb of the baker that we looked at last time.
In fact,
if you look at this site plan,
you see the trap is idle plan of the tomb of the baker right here.
And when we discuss the tomb of the baker,
I made the point to you that it was located or recited in front of a great gate,
the so called Puerto majority or the great gate,
uh,
that was,
that,
that spanned two aqueducts.
And I said to you,
I urge you to think away that a great gate,
uh,
because it was built later,
it was built.
In fact,
during the reign of Claudius,
we're going to look at it.
And momentarily.
So you see the great gate here and you see,
uh,
the tomb of the baker.
Uh,
and that gives you a sense of the location of the basilica,
the underground basilica of 50 a d.
If you look at that facility,
you see the plan is exactly like the basilica in a civic context.
The basilica at Pompei for example,
with a central nave and two side aisles,
a divided by that knave,
that central space,
uh,
through,
through architectural members in this case,
through peers rather than columns.
And then at the end to give some emphasis to one short side of this space,
a,
an apps that you also see there.
This is,
this underground basilica was used for religious worship.
So we see once again what I've referred to as the interchangeability of form,
the idea of creating a certain building plan for a civic center,
the law court or Basilica,
and then using it in other ways.
We already saw the Basilican plan being used in house design at Herculaneum as a
banqueting hall.
And here we see it as a religious place for religious worship underground.
Uh,
a basilican form being used for religious worship under ground.
The underground basilica is miraculously preserved.
Why?
Because it's underground.
And,
uh,
it didn't,
it consequently was,
uh,
was kept in very good shape over time.
It's very difficult to get permission to go down and see it.
But it is a marvel,
as you can see from this image here.
How did they create this underground basilica?
How did they make this building underground?
Well,
they cut trenches in the two far rock and the two far rock.
Remember we've talked about how ubiquitously too for rock was in,
in Rome,
uh,
both,
on,
on the hillsides like the Palatine and elsewhere.
So they cut trenches in the Tufa rock and then they poured concrete into those
trenches to create the walls.
Uh,
and also the barrel vault that you see so well here.
And once that concrete had dried,
uh,
they cut it out in such a way as to create the peers that you also see very well
in this structure.
So we're looking at that central space.
We're looking at the peers,
the arches above those peers,
uh,
and then that supporting a barrel vaulted ceiling as well as a semi bolt in the
apps of this structure.
Another view,
gives you a sense of the relationship of the central space to the isles.
It's a fairly small structure,
but nonetheless it is quite light and airy as I think you can see here.
As we look from the central nave toward one of the side Oz can see the peers and
the arches above those peers.
And you can also see the way in which the walls are decorated.
They're made out of concrete,
but they're stuck out over and divided into a series of panels that are
decorated with pretty strong resemblance to third style.
And that resemblance becomes even clearer as we look up to the vault above a,
this is how we,
we surmise that this building was put up to the neo Pythagorean cult because the
figures that we see floating in the central panels here,
uh,
those who have a good understanding of the neopathy jaggery and called have
suggested that these track,
uh,
extremely well.
The beliefs of this particular cult,
but interesting for us is again,
the close resemblance of this to third style Roman wall painting.
It's done in Stucco.
The stucco was painted,
but you can see it's divided into a series of panels with floating mythological
figures.
It's our floating religious figures in this case,
inside the panels.
And look then very carefully at some of the floral decorations,
which you will see also resemble very closely the flimsy candelabra and so on
that are characteristic of third style Roman painting.
This shouldn't surprise you,
the data 50 and is still well within the third style.
We talked about the very long life of the third style that it was used already
in the late first century BC,
but that it didn't really go out until about 62,
a d so 50.
We're still in that period of the third style.
It doesn't surprise us,
uh,
to see decoration like this in this very interesting underground basilica.
Caligula was murdered,
uh,
in,
at the end of it was murdered and he and 41 and his wife and daughter,
he had one daughter were also murdered at the same time.
He had no family member to succeed.
Him and his uncle Claudius,
uh,
was chosen as the next emperor of Rome.
Many of you may know the interesting story at the quite captivating story of
how,
uh,
it,
Claudius was chosen as emperor.
He was someone who is not highly respected by his family.
And I'll say more about that in a moment.
No one ever thought he was going to amount to anything I,
and when after Caligula's death,
uh,
Claudius was such kind of timid,
that he hid behind a curtain.
But as the Praetorian guard wandered through the palace trying to figure out who
in the world they were going to a point as Caligula's success,
if they saw a pair of feet underneath the curtain,
they pulled open that curtain and they saw Claudius and they thought,
oh,
he's going to be no trouble at all.
No one thinks much of him.
We're going to be able to get everything we want if we appoint Claudia's as
emperor.
And so they did.
They bowed down and they said,
you are now where they put him up on their shoulders.
You are now emperor of Rome.
Well,
Claudia,
surprise them because he was very smart individual.
Indeed,
as we shall see,
this is a cameo,
a famous cameo that represents Claudius,
just for you to get some sense of what he looked like over here on the left with
his wife,
and then possibly these two figures over here,
controversial possibly with Tiberius or some other member of the imperial
family.
This is blown up into colossal size.
It's a fairly small but very beautiful.
Cami on these cameos were used as presentation pieces in ancient Roman Times.
Claudia's was emperor of Rome.
Between Aidy 41 and 54 he,
I mentioned that his family did not have much respect for him.
They thought he was weak and sickly and they thought he was dimwitted.
And the only reason they thought he was dimwitted because the poor fellow
stammered.
And they thought that that reflected,
uh,
a,
an undisciplined mind.
Not at all.
He was very,
very intelligent indeed,
and he surprised them.
He surprised not only the Praetorian guard,
but also his family.
When he became emperor.
He turned out to be a unique individual with a predilection.
As we shall see,
you bought a,
an entirely new kind of,
uh,
and very distinctive form of architecture and one that I believe,
and I'll try to make the case due today,
reflect,
reflected his very distinctive intellect.
We need to know therefore something about him and how he came and had what he,
how he had trained himself intellectually before he became emperor of Rome.
He was 50 years old when he became emperor.
He had been in the years prior to that,
a scholar and a historian,
an antiquarian,
a linguist,
he wrote a history of Rome by himself,
was not ghost written.
And he wrote several volumes also on his own,
on the trust skins.
He was particularly interested in the Etruscans.
We know he added a few letters to the Latin alphabet to give it more range.
And he was the last as far as we know,
to be able to read and also write a trust.
And this gives you a very good sense of the man.
Uh,
with regard to architecture.
He rejected categorically the interest of Tiberius and Caligula in villa
architecture.
And he returned to the construction of public architecture.
He looked to Augustus as a model for this and especially to public works.
Let me show you one example.
You see on the screen a site plan of the port of Rome.
Uh,
W we,
I've already mentioned the fact that the port of Rome was located at Osteon
Ostia,
the city at the mouth of the Tiber river.
We saw the plan of Ostia I colony already founded in the mid fourth century BC
and around three 50 and it grew over time and it had its efflorescence as we'll
see in a later lecture in the second century.
Aidy here,
the plan of,
uh,
of,
of a Ostia over here,
the Tiber River,
and then at the mouth of the Tiber river at a place that we call Portas,
a location that we call portals or Porto.
It's on the monument list for you.
The actual harbor itself.
What we're looking at above is a coin of the Emperor Nero.
You see neuro on the arbors and on the reverse,
a representation of what we think is the port built by Claudius.
We have a description of the port of Claudius by Sue Atonia [inaudible],
uh,
in his lives.
Sua Tony is,
tells us that the port had curving breakwaters curving breakwaters.
Uh,
and if we look at this coin of neuro that was struck,
uh,
by,
by the emperor between 64 and 68 a d we see on the back,
uh,
what is clearly a port with curving breakwaters.
So we believe that this must be a depiction of the port built built by Claudia
sometime during his reign that is between 41 and 54.
What does that coin tell us about what that,
uh,
port must've looked like?
We can see that there is a large statue in the upper center.
There is a river God reclining below probably the Tiber himself to locate,
uh,
this port a and also a series of boats in the center.
But most important,
again,
are the curving break waters,
which you can see are made up of a series of columns.
They look like colonnades one on either side,
curving colonnades.
This plan down here,
uh,
shows us the likely plan of the Claudia and harbor,
roughly circular,
uh,
again with breakwaters on either side with columns on either side.
This area was added to by the Emperor Trajan,
the early second century aids.
He added a five sided,
uh,
port as well.
And you can see that here in this plan as well.
But think that away for now.
All that would have been there was Claudius is port with the curving break
waters.
This is a painting of both of those ports that's on the wall and the Vatican.
I walked by in many times and only recently really noticed it and took a picture
of it and I think it'll be helpful to you today because it gives you a sense of
what this port looked like in antiquity equity.
We see the later port of trade and over here,
but again,
think that away for now and concentrate on the curving break waters of Claudia
says port.
You see here,
this colossal statue,
possibly of Neptune over here.
Uh,
a light house over here and uh,
the boats in the center of this.
But most important for us,
again,
are those curving break waters and the fact that they were made up of columns.
The columns are all that survived today and what a set of columns they are.
Uh,
I show a detail of some of them to you here and you should be struck by these
columns because these are columns unlike any other columns that we have seen in
the course of this semester.
If you look at these columns very carefully,
you will see,
uh,
that the base that the capital's on the top,
which are very severe,
they're not exactly the doric order,
but they resemble the doric order,
very severe.
Uh,
and they are finished.
You can,
you can identify them as capitals and the bases.
I'll show you a view of a basis in a moment.
The basis as we'll also see are also finished with very nice moldings down
below.
But in between the bases and the capitals,
we see something again that we've never seen before.
And that is a series of drums of column drums piled one on top of another.
But those drums are not finished or they're left in a rough state,
one or the other.
They have either been deliberately left in a Russ rough or [inaudible] state or
they were unfinished.
Why might they have been unfinished?
They might've been unfinished because the project was,
was uh,
it was,
it was late.
They were rushing it.
They want it to get it done.
They needed to use the harbor.
And so they said,
look,
to save time,
just put those columns up the way they are and don't bother finishing the drums
of the column.
Or it might have had or one could argue that it might have had to do with
expense,
that it was getting too expensive and then they decided not to finish,
uh,
the drums for that reason.
Or it might have been deliberate or it might've been deliberate.
The idea to leave those drums rough,
to make them look [inaudible].
I'm going to make a case today that it's the last,
that this was a deliberate move on Claudius and his architects and one of the
main reasons I can make that if this is all we had,
if we had only this port of Claudius,
only these columns in this style,
it would be very difficult to make the case.
But as we're going to see when we moved from this to that great gate or the port
of majority,
which was put up under Claudius and then not today,
but next time to a building that was put up and Claudius is honor after his
death,
we will see that all three of those have these rust dicated columns or peers in,
in common.
Uh,
which suggests to us,
that suggest to me for sure,
uh,
that these are these,
that,
that leaving them in this Russ dicated state was deliberate on the part of the
patron and his architects.
And I'm also going to suggest that it had to do,
uh,
with,
with Claudius is peculiar personality and especially his interest in
antiquarianism in the past and the history of Rome and the history of the trust
skins and so on.
Here's another detail,
a of one of the columns over here where you can see the rough drum and then down
below the base on which that sits,
a molded bay based very carefully molded the architects,
the designers,
the artisans could,
could finish these columns perfectly well if they chose to.
They did it on the base.
They did it in the capitals,
but not in between.
Here's another one where you can see a series of columns engaged into a wall.
Uh,
and again,
you can see the rough or rust dicated drums.
Then down below the molded,
the finished finished basis.
So this difference between what we call finished masonry or dressed dres,
SCD dressed masonry or rust dicated,
masonry,
that is deliberately left rough.
Again,
in order to underscore this point,
I want to turn now to the great gate or the Porta majority in Rome.
Also built by Claudius between 41 and 54 had you already know its location near
the tomb of your recipes,
uh,
near the underground basilica that we also discussed today.
And I had mentioned to you already that the purpose of this gate was to uh,
serve as a crossing point for two aqueducts,
aqueducts that had been begun earlier,
were worked on by Calendula,
uh,
and then completed by Claudius and there were two of them,
two of them that crossed at this very point and they needed something to mask
that crossing.
And so they built this great gate.
The porter majority,
if you look at this general view of the port,
a majority,
you will see much of what I have already described.
It has to open archways the upper most part,
which is the attic which has an inscription.
It's a three tiered attic as you can see.
And you can,
if you look carefully,
you will see it as an extensive inscription making reference to Claudius and to
the aqueducts.
And so on,
uh,
down below we see a series of smaller occupations surrounded by a columns on
either side,
supporting pediments above.
If you look closely,
you can see that the pediments are finished,
pediments are finished,
the lintels are finished,
the capitals are finished,
uh,
bought the blocks of the column and the blocks of the rest of the structure are
left in a hated state.
They are not finished.
And we see that very stark difference between the rustic catered masonry and the
finished masonry,
the smooth masonry,
the dressed masonry and the rough masonry in this structure.
This arch bought this gate by the way,
is made out of travertine,
travertine cut stone construction.
Here's another view that I think shows you better the way in which this gate
masks the crossing of those two aqua ducks.
A,
you can see a two channels there and the one one would have had pipes running
through it one way and the other would have had pipes running through it the
other way and that's how they crossed in antiquity.
And I'll show you a model that may make that even clearer in a moment.
You can also see the location of the tomb of the baker,
your Rissa keys right next to the so called Puerto Majora.
Here's the model that I showed you when we looked at the tomb of your risk,
the keys,
the way in which the prime to Stina and the lobby Kona come into Rome and
converge at the facade of that tomb.
A here you see the great gate or porter majority behind it.
And this is the best,
the best illustration I can give of the way in which those two,
the pipes of the two aqueducts crossed behind the attic of the gate,
which is one of the reasons it had to be as tall as it did.
And one of the reasons it had to have tears,
uh,
was in order because it was separated,
behind.
You can see that very well here as well as the rest Decatur.
The contrast between the recirculated masonry and the finished masonry of this
great gate.
This combination of the two is,
uh,
is,
is a very mannered thing to do.
And it's interesting that later renaissance architects in Italy.
Uh,
and for those of you who are aficionados of the,
of the renaissance,
you may know the work of an architect by the name of Julio Romano who created
the great,
the famous Palazzo del Tay in Mantua.
And I show you a detail of the Palazzo Delta.
Just to make the point,
the more general point,
you don't have to worry about Julio,
but just to make the general point,
uh,
that these renaissance architects like Giulio Romano looked back,
to buildings like the porter majority in Rome when they also conceived a
buildings in which they contrast it.
Russ dicated masonry with a smooth masonry,
as you can also see so well and here too,
last details of the port of majority.
And I think these show you almost more than anything else I have thus far.
Uh,
this incredible contrast between the finished and the unfinished masonry between
the smooth and the rough.
Uh,
and here you see,
you can see a detail of the pediment of the smoothness of that,
of the lintel down below of the capitol,
which is completely finished.
And then even of the upper most part of the column,
and this is a particularly interesting detail I think because it gives me the
sense as I look at it,
uh,
that the,
what the arc at patron and architects are trying to do is give us a sense that
the column actually lives inside the rustic gated drums.
I get the sense as I look at this,
that this finished column is just,
is very anxious to bust out of the [inaudible] masonry and winded,
which it is confined.
It's very anxious to,
to,
uh,
to emerge from that rustic dicated masonry.
And I,
I can't help but think of the renaissance again and especially of Michelangelo
for any of you who've seen his slaves and the academia in Florence,
uh,
the slaves that seem to,
he took these big blocks of Carrara marble and he try,
he represents the slaves as if they are still immersed in that marble.
But trying to break free from that marble is if these,
these images of human beings,
we're somehow,
I'm located inside that marble and just waiting for the genius Michelangelo to
free them from that marble.
It's the same sense that I get here when I look at this and it makes me think
again that a very intelligent,
uh,
a very refined mind,
is behind sorting out this kind of thing and conceiving of something of this
nature and given the,
uh,
the education and the bent of Claudia C as just the kind of man who might have
done that.
And I think we need to see the architecture of Claudius,
this rustic hated architecture of Claudius and sophisticated architecture of
Claudia's,
which is contrasted to the smooth and finished architecture at the same time as
something that really is reflective of the peculiar personality of this man.
I think it's also important to say though that this kind of architecture at this
time is very old fashioned.
The whole idea of using cut stone travertine construction after what we've seen
is going on in concrete construction is a very old fashioned thing to do.
It again shows us a man who is looking to the past was looking to the history of
Rome,
to the history of the Etruscans perhaps rather then to the present,
uh,
at,
but,
but on the positive side,
one could also say,
uh,
that what he is doing here he is using stone construction,
but he is using it in a very different way.
And indeed and almost anti classical way to the way in which Augustus used to
think of Augustus is our pockets.
Think of Augustus is a temple of Marzel tour in the forum of Augustus in Rome.
Both of those,
uh,
marble buildings,
in that case,
Luna or Carrara marble based on ancient Greek prototypes.
This is also stone architecture and in that sense,
again,
old fashioned,
but it's travertine,
not marble.
Uh,
but it is anti classical in,
in its use of this rustic skated as well as smooth masonry.
So I do want you to ponder this architecture of,
of Claudius and,
and think for yourselves about whether you think,
again,
it is,
do the form that it takes is due to the very interesting and unusual personality
of this one man from,
uh,
Claudius.
I want to turn to the notorious Nero and his amazing architectural legacy.
Uh,
and you see a portrait of neuro here on the right hand side of the screen.
and a coin,
uh,
with his mother on the left,
the mother of Nero was Agra Pina,
the younger Agra Pina,
the younger was the last wife of Claudius and it was rumored that ag Repina,
the younger murdered Claudius with a bowl of poisoned mushrooms.
Uh,
we don't know if that's true or not.
It may be just rumormongering.
Uh,
but it's perfectly conceivable because she certainly had a motive and that is
she thought she would have more power if her teenage son,
cause he was only about 17 years old at the time,
was on the throne of Rome instead of her older husband.
And this coin that you see on the left hand side of the screen of the young
neuro and Agra Pina,
I think says it all.
I mean,
mother and son,
almost nose to nose.
Uh,
this,
this gives real meaning to,
to being in your face.
As you can see here.
Uh,
I'd repeat,
peanut is certainly in the face of neuro on this coin and she was with regard to
his life dominating him in the very early years of his reign.
Neuro was born in [inaudible] 37.
He was emperor between 54 and 68.
At his death.
His murder has his,
he was forced to commit suicide actually,
uh,
in 68,
he suffered a dumb not too Memoria,
uh,
which was a condemnation by the Senate,
of him,
a damnation of his memory and an attempt to destroy his portraits and also his
architectural monuments of followed that dumb not to know.
Memoria Nero was the last of the Julio,
Claudia and emperors.
He was as he was the adoptive son of Claudius.
And as I've already mentioned,
the real son of Claudius,
his last wife,
Agra Pina.
The elder.
I mentioned already that Agora [inaudible] gave you the sense that I grew up ina
was a cra,
quite,
uh,
aggressive,
woman who aggravated Claudia's EdNeuro both.
We talked about the poisoned mushroom stories,
uh,
and the fact that the,
the,
when,
when her son became emperor,
she received at least for a while,
enhance power in Rome.
But Nero eventually paid his mother back by having her murdered in [inaudible]
59,
he also got rid of his wife Octavia,
beautiful young girl whom he had murdered in [inaudible] 62.
So by the age of 25,
Nero had gotten rid of the women,
the two women who had dominated his youth and his much touted madness.
He was not unlike Caligula and some of the wild things that he did as much
touted madness began to appear.
That said,
despite his madness,
he was absolutely adored by the populace.
It was a great show to watch neuro and people liked seeing what he would do
next.
He was adored by the populous.
He was however hated by the aristocracy.
And in 68,
he was hunted down by his enemies and he was forced to commit suicide.
I would call Nero,
uh,
a patron of architecture.
Extraordinary.
His contribution to the development of Roman architecture is indeed
extraordinary.
He had a passion for the arts,
which undoubtedly lead to his devotion to building.
He wrote in these sang poems.
Neuro was a musician.
He collected Greek works of art.
He traveled to Greece to participate in the Olympics.
Whenever he did that,
they were always fixed in his favor.
He stole when he traveled around Greece and Asia Minor,
he stole.
If he saw a work of art he liked,
he's stolen and he brought it back to Rome to display.
He interwove his life with his art in the same manner as Claudius did.
He took a,
he took advantage of that very famous fire in Rome,
which took place in 64.
A D to a legend has it that he fiddled while Rome burned.
He wasn't fiddling actually,
but he was participating in some sort of musical performance.
We know that,
uh,
and after,
the fire raged through the city and caused incredible havoc and great
destruction,
what Nero did was instead of rebuilding the land for the people of Rome,
he just expropriated or he expropriated 300 to 350 acres of prime real estate in
downtown Rome.
And he used it to build his own villa,
his own palace in the center of Rome,
the famous Domus our area or golden house because it had a gilded facade.
Neuros architecture was intimately bound up with the vicissitudes of his life
and his distinctive,
if not warped personality as we shall see,
neuro belt,
two palaces in Rome.
And I'd like to begin with the one,
uh,
the with,
with,
I would like to deal with those in consecutive order.
The first of these,
as you can see from his,
from the monument list,
is the so-called domus transitory or the less well known one and less
WellPreserved one.
The Dome is transitory in Rome.
A that was built sometime before the fire,
before [inaudible] 64,
because it was very significantly destroyed in that fire of d 64.
I'm showing you a Google map,
Google earth image of the part of Rome in which this building found itself.
We are looking down,
we've seen this one before.
We are looking down at the Roman forum,
the Coliseum and the upper most part there,
the Palatine Hill over here.
Uh,
and uh,
if we follow the Roman forum toward the Coliseum and toward the arch of the
later arch of Constantine,
we will see that there is spur hill over here.
And that spur hell is located between the Palatine Hill and one of Rome's other
hills.
The Escalade,
the Escalade Hill Nero's dream was to link the buildings that were going up on
the Peloton.
We've already talked about the imperial palace begun by Tiberius a continued by
Colliculi.
Claudius had no interest in that,
uh,
but then neuro returns to it and he's continuing to build this palace on the
Palatine.
But his dream is to link that with property that he also owns on the Escalade
and hill.
And to make one truly grandiose palace,
uh,
that links those two hills across a spur hill called the Veolia v e l I a,
which is in this upper most part of the Roman forum closest to the Coliseum.
That was his dream.
And he began to try to realize it prior to 64.
And the building is called the Dome is transitory because it served as a point
of transit between those two hills,
between the Palatine and the Escalade hills.
Again,
because it was so seriously destroyed in fire.
And also because it was deliberately,
uh,
deliberately,
destroyed by later and Bruce who were following the damnation,
the dom,
not Geo Memoriae,
the damnation of Nero's memory and felt that that was there,
right in the sense to destroy his buildings.
So those two things together,
deliberate destruction plus the fire essentially destroyed.
Most of the Dome is transitory,
but a couple of sections are preserved underground and they're very important
for us to look at because they give us insight into the latest go to the later
golden house or domes area.
I want to show you the two sections that are still preserved,
uh,
in restored views that you will find in your textbook.
And Ward Perkins,
one of these is located beneath the,
uh,
while this is still on the screen,
if you look at the Palatine policy or just a little bit up beyond where my
finger is,
there is the,
uh,
the dining hall of the later for a century,
a d palace that we'll look at a soon next week.
Um,
you see it there.
And uh,
one of the buildings,
a fountain of Nero's Domus transitory is located under that.
And then over here,
this temple that you see right close to the coliseum is a later Hadrian Anik
temple of Venus and Roma.
The domed room that I'm going to show you is under that.
So both of these are underground beneath a later structures.
This is a restored view from Ward Perkins of the,
uh,
of the Fountain,
the Fountain Court of Nero's Domus transitory.
And we see a number of important features.
We see an open court with a pool,
with columns around it.
We see on the northern wall over here we see the fountain itself.
We see that what the architects have done is create,
use a niche,
a place in that niche,
a series of other niches that served as the location of the actual uh,
water from which the fountain emerged and the water would cascade over this,
uh,
this wall down here and then end up in a long basin in front of it.
The Wall is what's most interesting.
If you look at it,
you will see that it is essentially scalloped,
uh,
with columns in the front.
And then additional columns in the receiving bay is creating a kind of in and
out effect,
very similar to a theater architecture.
And I show you a restored view of a typical uh,
theater,
uh,
of,
of earlier date.
It just to give you a sense of what this is based on.
You can also see that opening up off the central court,
screened by columns are barrel vaulted rooms on either side.
These were used as special dining areas and special dining areas with beautiful
views out onto this fountain court on either side and this,
and then this restored view also gives you a sense that uh,
the pavements were very gated,
were done in different designs and we know that these pavements were made out of
marble and that the walls were prevented with marble.
This isn't the full marble of the first style.
This is real marble and it's our first example in Rome,
a of a,
uh,
of,
of a room that was reverted with marble brought from all parts of the world.
Marble brought from Africa,
marble brought from Egypt,
marble brought from Asia minor and also from Greece in various colors to
decorate the fountain court of Nero's Domus transitory.
The other room,
and perhaps the more important of the two is the domed room.
Definitely more important of the two.
The dome drew in the Dome is transitory of Nero and you see a restored view of
it here.
What are we dealing with?
We are dealing with a build a structure that is clearly based on the thermal
bath at by and the frigate Daria pump pay.
It is a concrete,
uh,
structure.
Uh,
it looks as if it's round.
In fact,
you can see a circle inscribed in the,
in the pavement down here below,
the structure is made out of concrete.
It has a dome and an Oculus.
But even though that it is inscribed in the circle,
if you look carefully at the walls,
you will see that although they are curved,
they follow the curvature of the circle.
There are eight sides to this wall.
So the architect is starting to explore the idea of an octagon.
This is not an octagon.
It's a circle inscribed in an octagon in a sense.
Uh,
but it is an exploration into an eight sided form that we're going to see is
very,
very important,
uh,
for a later development in the Golden House of Nero.
Uh,
it also,
what we see here that's very interesting,
that's a further development of the Frigidaire Doriam and thermal bath idea is
instead of this circular circular structure in an octagon ending with these
radiating apps as the four rating a radiating apps is that we saw at Baia for
example,
we see that they extend into Carter's on either side,
which expands the space in a way that we have not seen before.
You see,
they don't end on either side.
With these,
with these apps is with walls,
they expand into these long carters.
As you can see,
creating a kind of cross shape and certainly adding uh,
to uh,
the interesting spatial relationships in spatial as spatial possibilities.
And the use again of Vista and Panorama as we've seen.
We see here also on either side here,
uh,
a series of columns with metal grills on top,
so wonderful views through those columns,
uh,
to what lies beyond.
And then on this side,
they small pool that had white marble and then colored marbles around that.
So you have to imagine again,
the overall appearance of this and antiquity when Wa light would have streamed
through the dome of the central space onto the walls.
It probably had mosaic on them through the grills and the columns onto the water
of the white pool here,
which was also surrounded with very gated marbles.
The same marbles brought from all over the world.
The view must have been quite spectacular.
Uh,
this is certainly,
again,
a form of ostentatious palatial architecture,
uh,
that,
Augustus issued but was becoming of increasing interest to the likes of Tiberius
Caligula and ultimately Nero.
And again,
uh,
just,
just to make the same point again,
that we can trace this back to the experiments of the Frig Adare at palm pay.
That's a star being bounced to the thermal bath,
the temple of Mercury at Baia.
But look at the difference that it makes when you extend those apps is into
Carter's,
uh,
creating a much freer a spatial situation and adding to the Vista and Panorama,
the idea that has been so popular as we've long seen with the Romans and the
time that remains [inaudible].
I want to return,
I want to turn to a is most important,
uh,
architectural commission.
And I can't overemphasize the significance of this structure that I'm going to
show you now.
The so called Domo salary or the Golden House of neuro,
again,
because of its gilded facade,
we've already talked about the fire that raged through Rome and 64,
and that when that fire,
when the smoke from that fire died down,
that Nero expropriated 300 to 350 acres in prime,
downtown Rome,
uh,
for his own use for a private palace,
the so called Golden House,
we see a site plan here also from Ward Perkins where you can get a sense not
only of the extent of this,
look how it,
how it,
it,
uh,
it covers ground from the circus maximus all the way across to the SQL line
hill.
Uh,
as you can see,
so well here,
so the Palatine Hill,
the Escalade,
Neil,
and also even the Caelian Hill over here,
he dug an artificial,
or he had his architects dig an artificial lake in the center of this,
as you can see here.
Uh,
and the Golden House was very extensive.
There's only one part of it that remains today,
uh,
under the,
or as part of the ESCO line hill in Rome and we therefore call it the Escalade
and wing of the Dome is our area of Nero.
This palace had an incredible set of Gimmicks,
gimmicks that were so noteworthy that the names of the architects of come down
to us,
the architect and engineer who are responsible for this.
And I think it is largely,
they came down to us largely because of these incredible gimmicks that they
created for this structure.
Their names were Severus and Keller Severus and Keller.
And I believe I have put their names on the monument in this for you.
Yes,
I have.
Underneath the plan of the Espolon wing.
So Severus in Keller,
their names suggest to us that they were a Roman architects.
In fact,
uh,
and these gimmicks included a 125 foot statue of Nero himself,
a colossal statue or the colossus as it is designated here,
a colossal statue of Nero with the feature neuro assimilated to the sun god Sol,
Sol.
The Sun God saw,
uh,
and it was done in bronze and it was done by a famous artist whose name we also
know Zena Doris.
I've also put his name on the monument list for you.
[inaudible],
who was a very famous bronze caster.
So Zina Doris is colossus,
uh,
the gilded facade.
Uh,
and what were some of the gimmicks that a severance and Keller added to this
palace?
When you,
when you ate in the dining hall,
if you were invited as a special guest to eat with Nero while you were eating a,
they coffered ceilings of one of the dining rooms would drop on you.
Uh,
all kinds of wonderful fragrance fragrances and flower petals while you ate.
there was also a bath that gave you a choice of,
uh,
of,
of seawater and,
um,
uh,
salt water and it's water from the sulfur springs of Tivoli.
You had your choice if you were bathing,
it narrows.
Don't Miss Aria.
And most spectacularly of all.
And I think what a severance and Keller had particular fame for was they created
a banqueting room that had a revolving ceilings,
supposedly a ceiling that revolve with the heavenly body.
So an incredible array of,
uh,
of Gimmicks,
as I said before in this extraordinary a palace.
But all of them clearly possible,
uh,
Visa v architecture.
At this time,
I'm showing you here a plan of the eschalon wings is the one part of the palace
that survives today.
We'll talk about what happened to this palace in a later lecture,
uh,
but you can see it here,
dozens and dozens of rooms around a five sided court,
as you can see at this location.
And then here,
what is up to this,
what is,
what is the so called octagonal room of Nero's Domus area,
which is a remarkable room.
And I think it's fair to say the single most important room that I will have
shown you thus far this semester is the octagonal room of neuros.
Don't miss area.
And you see it here.
You can see the plan of the octagon and then the radiating spaces out from it.
I'll return to that plan.
And just a moment,
just to mention though,
by using Google earth again,
I can show you the particular location of the Dome of the Escalade wing on the
Po,
on the Escalade Hill today.
Uh,
what happened to it eventually,
and again,
I'm not going to go into the details now,
but I will in the future.
Uh,
the after Nero's dumb not to a memorial,
I,
some of this was destroyed.
Much of it was incorporated into later buildings.
Uh,
eventually a bath,
uh,
of the emperor Trajan ended up on this site and the emperor,
they covered over what was remained of Nero's domus salary,
what hadn't been raised to the ground and incorporated some of it into his later
bath.
Uh,
and in fact,
this hemi cycle of Trajan is bath is actually the entrance way today of the Dome
is salary.
You can see it right here and you can see that the other remains of both Trajan
is bads and of the domus salary had been incorporated into a modern garden,
a very attractive garden where you can wander and see some of the remains of
both.
And actually what you see here,
it just shows you how amazing Google earth is.
This circle that you see here is actually,
it has a great on top today,
but it is actually the Oculus of Nero's octagonal room,
which is down below,
which is located underground.
So if you visit the miss our IA,
which is as you can see right near the coliseum,
you go into the entrance way through the Hemi cycle of trade gins,
later Baz,
and you find yourself in a series of corridors.
We've talked about these Carter's before because we talked about the paintings
that fabulous did a four Nero's Doma salary at first,
the third style paintings,
and then the fourth style paintings.
And you'll remember that they don't miss our AEA was described as fabulous as
prison because there was so many rooms and Carter's that it would take a whole
lifetime to paint them.
And you see some of those here,
barrel vaulted,
Carter's a stuccoed over,
uh,
and then painted in the third and fourth styles.
Uh,
another gimmick that you see throughout the,
um,
the don't miss our AEA are a series of bridges that are built to carry water
from one part of the palace to another.
Another view here,
a showing one of the carters.
And what you see here is something that we have not discussed yet,
but as the wave of the future and that is concrete faced with brick after the
fire,
there was realization the fire of 64,
there was realization that stone burn too easily.
It was not an effective facing any longer,
uh,
and that they needed to come up with something else.
A brick was work better with fire.
So the decision was taken to move and this is not the tile,
brick and palm.
This is real brick.
Uh,
and the decision was taken to begin to use brick face construction for these
buildings.
At this time it was stuccoed over,
as you can see here,
stucco and then painted on top.
So you wouldn't have actually seen the brick in antiquity,
but we'll see.
It was not long until the Romans recognize that brick was a very attractive
material in its own right and began to leave it exposed,
but we're not there yet.
The paintings,
the fourth style paintings and fabulous,
you'll remember this one that we've already looked at with the reintroduction of
architectural fragments and the architectural cages in the domes area.
This is the single,
as I've already said,
the single most remarkable and important room that I've shown you thus far this
semester.
The octagonal room in Nero's Domus area.
You see this across section plan and axonometric view from Ward Perkins here,
and you can get a very good sense of this.
This is truly an octagonal room.
The experiment in the Dome Room where they had inscribed a circle into an
octagon gave them the idea that they were going to try to make an actual
octagonal room out of concrete and they succeed.
Here you can see the eight sides of this room.
You can see it has a series of radiating alcoves,
but much bigger alcoves.
Then we saw it in the frig or Daria at palm pay or in the thermal bath that via
a and differently shaped ones and not,
you know,
all the same.
Uh,
but when one couple of cross shaped and others are rectangular different shapes
and then the accident,
a metric view shows you that within those alcoves uh,
there are additional niches in some of the walls that gives a more of a
sculptural quality to this then has been the case before.
And this again was no small feat on the part of these architects.
Why is the Domus hour he is so important?
The reason I,
the,
excuse me,
the octagonal room of the Dome is our area so important.
The octagonal room of the Domus area,
and I'm giving you a number of bullet points here,
represents a break from the tyranny of the rectangle,
the tyranny of the rectangle that we know from Greek and a trust can
architecture.
It enables vistas to be created in every direction and you know,
the importance to Roman's of vistas and panoramas.
It creates one continuous envelope around an interior space.
It fully realizes this development has been long in coming.
But we're finally there.
It fully realizes the technical and expressive potentiality of Roman concrete
construction.
It represents a switch of emphasis from solids to voids from walls and roofs
that we saw in such buildings as a temple of Port Tunis to the end.
Substantial space that they enclose and shape.
It is the interior space,
not the walls that matter now and in this new interior architecture,
light plays a key role,
natural light that creates drama as well as illuminates the importance of the
octagonal room of narrows.
Domus Aria can not be overstated.
Exclamation point,
exclamation point,
exclamation point.
The octagonal room,
Harold's,
the Roman architectural revolution that we saw already beginning at places like
Palestrina,
but it is finally here and it's full blown form where as I said,
the potentiality of the expressiveness of Roman concrete is fully realized.
This is the room itself as it looks today.
Uh,
we can see,
uh,
the octagon.
We can see the dome,
we can see the way in which the octagon becomes the dome,
the eight sides,
and the way it is shaped to become the dome above.
We can see some of the niches here.
We can see the way in which the,
the spaces that expand from the central space.
And we can see,
uh,
niches within those to give greater sculptural quality to it.
And you can get a little bit of the sense of the light here.
It,
this would have been elaborately decorated in antiquity.
I show you a restored view.
All of those same marbles from Egypt,
from Africa,
from,
uh,
Asia minor from Greece,
all brought together here.
Lots of different colors.
This is what those palm pay ins wished their walls actually looked like a,
but you see real marble reverted walls,
marble pavements,
and then up above and all kinds of colors.
And then up above the ceiling stuccoed over and also painted.
One can only imagine neuro,
uh,
entering into this octagonal room and how he must have felt.
And in fact,
we have a quote from Nero and in which he says that when the Dome is our area,
uh,
in Rome was finished,
or he is reported to have said,
when the dome is salary in Rome was finished,
he's reported to have said,
and I quote at last,
at last,
I am going to be able to be housed like a human being.
That was the way neuro thought about this.
He achieved his goal undoubtedly,
at least for a short period of time before,
uh,
before he died in 68.
Uh,
and I believe,
and I'm sure you agree with me,
I believe that it is for the dome is salary,
especially for the octagonal room of the Dome is our Ia.
That Nero would have liked to be remembered,
and indeed he achieved his goal.
Thank you.